bonjour karine berger goal of
commercially d'être avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france alors le discours elle
n'est pas aussi alarmant que celui d'
emmanuel macron mais globalement seriez
la vente elle ne dresse pas un bilan
très positif des nations unies
qu'en pensez vous bonjour il est quand
même difficile de dresser un bilan
positif
ils fonctionnement de l'onu aujourd'hui
pour la simple et bonne raison que sur
un certain nombre de dossiers sont
quasiment fait tous les dossiers
réellement important l'onu n'est plus
capable de régler les questions et la
situation montre à quel point en fait à
la fracture à l'intérieur de la
communauté internationale est
idéologique et non politique sur les
questions politiques vous pouvez
toujours trouver un compromis
lorsque vous avez un cours idéologiques
différents c'est absolument impossible
de trouver une solution commune et c'est
exactement ce que demande ce que
démontre ce blocage de l'onu du conseil
de sécurité
sachant que ça n'est certainement pas
une réforme à élargissant le nombre de
membres du conseil de sécurité comme le
propose merkel ou encore comme parfois
on en parle de la suppression du droit
de veto qui va régler la question
c'est un véritable problème de
confrontation idéologique actuellement
que nous sommes entrain de alors dans
son discours seriez l'avoir fait appel
au respect de la charte des nations
unies
est ce que le ministre russe vise un ou
plusieurs pays dans dans ce qu'il dit il
vise directement les etats-unis puissent
au minimum szyska les états unis héberge
les institutions fait une partie en tout
cas des institutions l'onu ça ne veut
pas dire qu'elles ont la maîtrise de
donner l'accès ou de ne pas donner
l'accès or on a vu la manière dont les
états unis utilisent le siège
géographique de ces institutions pour
permettre à des délégations russes par
exemple d'accéder ou de ne pas accéder
aux événements qui sont organisées dans
le cadre de l'onu ce qui est une
violation directe de la charte des 10
statues
vous parliez tout à l'heure de fractures
internationale à travers ce discours de
sérier la voie parce que on sent une
envie rue justement que que le climat
s'apaise
la russie a toujours eu et maintient
toujours un discours de conciliation ce
qui ne veut pas dire qu'elle va accepter
tout et n'importe quoi comme on voit si
on les traités a proposé la
renégociation que proposée par les états
unis sur les traités limitation des
armements la russie tech peut pas
accepter ça en revanche la russie ne
cherche pas la confrontation aller face
si vous voulez à un monde globalisé qui
se développe qui s'étend réellement de
plus en plus elle a accepté certaines
règles du jeu mais elle tient à défendre
son territoire sa vision des choses
son pays son état s'est en quelque sorte
cette fracture que l'on voit puisque les
ce qui est proposé actuellement dans le
monde global c'est la négation de l'état
donc nous avons ici un problème
fondamental entre les deux visions du
monde globaliste et atlantique au centre
et d'un côté d'autre part un pays à un
système fondé sur des états souverains
ce qui est proposé par la russie
aucune conciliation n'est possible dans
cette dans cette dualité
en revanche ça ne veut pas dire que la
russe
si veille elle une relation
conflictuelle
alors on l'a vu un tout à leurs salariés
lavrov n'est pas le seul à critiquer
l'organisation de de l'onu emmanuel
macron également l'a fait est-ce que
c'est toute une institution qui doit
revoir sa façon de faire sa façon de
s'organiser
il faut bien comprendre que le droit
international et les institutions qui
font fonctionner le droit international
ne sont que le résultat des rapports de
force sur la scène internationale
l'institution de l'onu telle que nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui est le résultat
du rapport de forces suite est la
seconde guerre mondiale où il y a eu un
certain équilibre qui a été atteint
entre le bloc de l'ouest tenue par les
états unis et le bloc de l'est tenu par
l'urss
je suis de l'urss a brouillé les cartes
la position de la russie aujourd'hui si
elle revient forte sur la scène
internationale n'est pas actuellement en
tout cas une puissance apte à bloquer
les phénomène de globalisation
donc il y a une certaine forme d'impasse
lorsqu'il ya une telle incertitude je ne
suis pas certaine que ce soit en tout
cas dans l'intérêt de la russie de
l'ensea et de participer le cautionner
un grand programme de remise à plat des
institutions politiques internationales
comme le nul pour la simple et bonne
raison que il n'est pas certain qu'elles
en sortent gagnantes il derrière vie en
tout cas ce qui est proposé
merci beaucoup car il met chez goal of
que d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france rappelle que vous êtes
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou merci beaucoup